et pour en parler en direct avec nous
christophe and pour lé directeur de
recherche à l'iris et spécialiste de
l'amérique latine bienvenu merci d'être
avec nous alors le rapprochement amorcé
par barack obama va-t-il s'accéléraient
avec joe biden base est en tout cas là
la feuille de route que ces données joe
biden lui-même puisque évidemment tout
le monde se souvient de barack obama et
de raul castro mais joe biden était déjà
disons très impliqué dans cette
normalisation des relations entre cuba
et washington en 2015 2014 2015 qui a
été traduit par un certain
assouplissement des conséquences de
l'embargo sur cuba que les cubains
rappelle blocus mais qui a coupé a été
coupé court par donald trump comme on
sait en 2016 puisqu'il est à resserrer
tout ce que obama et biden avait ouvert
les deux années auparavant alors
aujourd'hui by john a fait sa campagne
sur le fait que cuba était une des
priorités de sa politique étrangère pour
l'amérique latine et que dans ce
contexte là effectivement il voulait
revenir à l'esprit de la normalisation
de 2014 cependant après la victoire est
dans la période qui nous a menés
jusqu'au 14 décembre et lorsque les
grands électeurs l'ont confirmé
président valdonnez revenus un peu en
arrière un sur cuba parce qu'il a perdu
la floride entre temps parce qu'ils
pensent déjà en dirigeant politique aux
élections du midterm où les démocrates
ont besoin de gagner en floride est
aujourd'hui la floride est
majoritairement trump heist républicaine
et anti cubaines au sens quand il
autorités de la havane oculaire eu des
déclarations récemment plus dur de 10
ans qu'il ne céderait rien sur des
droits humains sur la démocratie ond les
sujets habituels de l'administration
américaine dans le consensus by paris
partie des américains
donc il va falloir quand même faire
attention parce que bayonne va avancer
aussi avec la pression de son aile un
peu néo conservatrice qui existe bien
sûr chez les républicains mais aussi au
sein des démocrates a alors si on va
vers une organisation en présentant des
relations entre cuba et les etats unis
concrètement comment cela peut-il se
traduire et bien falloir reprendre un
peu les dossiers là où vous avez été
vous ont été
un petit peu sa beauté par donald trump
il faut bien le dire pour les cubains
quelle est la chose importante est de
cannes elle le dit très bien dans
l'extrait que vous avez passé
ce qu'ils veulent c'est conserver bah
disons le modèle cubain le modèle
économique cubain donc qu'ils veulent
actualisé c'est la terminologie des
autorités de la havane
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils
veulent procéder à une ouverture de
l'économie partiel progressive sous
contrôle de l'état cubain une ouverture
de l'économie akwaba au secteur privé
aux investisseurs internationaux c'est
la priorité des priorités pour cuba que
le pays puisse recevoir des
investissements étrangers sans être
sanctionnés sans être sous les coups des
bâtons de la justice américaine c'est ça
qui est fondamental pour la havane est
aussi de permettre que lille continue
ils puissent recevoir et ben du tourisme
parce que le tourisme est devenu le
secteur sur lequel s'est appuyé cuba
pour penser disons sa transition
économique mais cela a été littéralement
balayée aussi par le cos vie de 19 est
donc l'enjeu est fondamental pour cuba
c'est l'ouverture de l'économie les
investisseurs internationaux et la
possibilité que les touristes puissent
venir à cuba
profitez du pays sans être inquiété par
les mesures économiques commerciales
financières de washington et que les
américains eux-mêmes les ressortissants
américains puissent venir comme il avait
commencé à le faire en nombre
massivement à partir de 2015 à cuba
qu'il puisse venir et bien à cuba comme
les cubains et c'est ça que veulent
négocier la havane ce qui veut dire
guidance est un peu ce que je vous
disais avant ça va dépendre un petit peu
des rapports de force internes à la
politique américaine
mais ce qu'il veut c'est aussi ça a
priori c'est permettre une établissement
des missions diplomatiques de des
échanges commerciaux et la possibilité
que les flux humains et marchandises et
financiers puissent transiter entre les
deux pays dans la du point de vue de
l'aube hayden et son illustration
c'est plutôt dans l'idée de finalement
apporté le secteur privé la consommation
de masse et ses plus bas pour que les
cubains abandonnés soit de changer de
modèle politique et de gouvernement
c'est là où les deux pays n'ont pas la
même appréciation
alors même si les relations entre les
deux pays s'améliore c'est imagine que
ne seront pas amicale
non c'est pas le mot qui convient
les relations entre cuba et les etats
unis sont complexes en fait un au delà
de la de l'affrontement qu'on connaît
c'est mais c'est quand même depuis 1959
une histoire qui ne laisse pas beaucoup
de place à l'amitié entre ces deux pays
c'est un rapport de force et donc c'est
un peu david contre goliath a commencé
mais en tout cas il peut y avoir
normalisation des rapports normaux
cordiaux diplomatiquement égal à ce que
peuvent être les relations entre tous
les pays de la planète c'est ça que
jusqu'où sont prêts à aller les deux
protagonistes pour des raisons à la fois
parfois convergentes nos six différentes
mais on peut pas encore parler d'une
amitié entre le gouvernement cubain est
celui de washington ce serait être abusé
un peu d'humour
merci christophe à 23 soit vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'iris et
spécialiste de l'amérique latine